[Applause]
as far as we know no one's ever
addressed the United States Congress in
a sweatshirt before but they love him
much more than they love you welcome to
Tucker Carlson site remember when Sam
bankman freed showed up in Washington
wearing a t-shirt and spouting nonsense
and all the self-described Geniuses
declared him a hero
the media the Congress the White House
they all love this weird little guy
called Sam bankman free do you remember
that
somehow we were reminded of it today
when the president of Ukraine arrived at
the White House dressed like the manager
of a strip club and started to demand
money amazingly no one threw him out and
said they did whatever he wanted
American taxpayers declared Joe Biden
will continue to give zielinski whatever
he demands for quote as long as it takes
tellingly Biden never specified what it
is as long as it takes to do what
push the Russian army back to
pre-invasion borders
sounds reasonable that's what most
Americans likely assume those who are
still paying attention but that is not
what zielinski means and it is not what
he is asking for
zelenski is demanding regime change in
Russia just like in Iraq in Libya and a
long list of other failed States except
this time in the heart of the Eurasian
land mass next door to the entire
civilized world
that's what zielinski has called for
repeatedly in every dollar we send to
him goes toward that end
at this point he's getting a lot closer
to achieving it so what happens if he
quote wins
what is the ensuing chaos look like
thought about that
who's going to secure the world's
largest nuclear Arsenal once we help
zielinski topple the Russian government
who replaces Putin
strangely those topics did not come up
today
because that wasn't the point the point
of today's visit to Washington was not
to make the world more stable or make
wise decisions much less to help America
that's always at the bottom of the list
the point was to fawn over the Ukrainian
strip club manager and hand him billions
more dollars from our own crumbling
economy
it is hard in fact it may be impossible
to imagine a more humiliating scenario
for the greatest country on Earth
and we would love to blame Joe Biden for
it but we can't really not entirely at
least this was bipartisan masochism
the uniparty is Alive and Well despite
the best efforts of Voters including
last month and if you doubt that it's
alive and well here's a picture of
zelenski that he had taken with a group
of elderly Republican senators in Kiev
back in May
they stand grinning next to him in their
orthopedic shoes 70 year old Susan
Collins John barrasso John cornyn led by
their 80 year old ringleader Mitch
McConnell 44 year old zielinski poses
between them in a skin-type polo shirt
flexing like a weightlifter and trying
to look ferocious they seem awestruck
not since a young Fidel Castro showed up
in New York wearing battle fatigues has
this country's aging leadership class
tittered more loudly in Delight they
love a man in uniform what a hunk so
strong and decisive
look at the expression of Mitch
McConnell's face you could almost hear
the giggles of pleasure
no rational person assessing the issues
ever would have predicted this moment
if you were a republican office holder
and zelenski came to Washington maybe
you would for a moment ask him about his
current and ongoing war against
Christianity in Ukraine especially if
you were say Mitch McConnell or John
cornyn and a lot of your own voters go
to church on Sunday they might care
about that issue
but McConnell and cornyn didn't mention
that they didn't say a word you will not
hear a word on television tonight about
the fact that zielinski has banned an
entire ancient Christian denomination in
Ukraine and then seized churches and
then thrown priests into jail
according to Mitch McConnell apparently
hasn't left his office since the mid 80s
anti-christian despotism is what most
Republicans want above all they don't
get enough they're just begging for it
watch McConnell explain
providing assistance for the ukrainians
to defeat the Russians
that's the number one priority for the
United States right now
according to most Republicans that's
sort of how we see the
challenges confronting the country at
the moment
and two other Senators stand behind him
nodding like it's true defeating Putin
is quote the number one priority among
Republicans says Mitch McConnell who
leads Republicans in the Senate number
one before our own economy or our own
Children's Schools or for that matter
before the more than 2 000 young people
killed last year by Fentanyl and Mitch
McConnell's quote home state of Kentucky
punishing Vladimir Putin for putting
Donald Trump in office is more important
than all of that
says Mitch McConnell Ukraine's borders
matter ours don't matter you may have
suspected they thought that oh but at
this point they're just coming out and
saying this right in your face
and of course the White House agrees
completely watch Mitch McConnell
announced today that you'll be paying
for ever more advanced weapon systems to
be sent to Ukraine whether you like it
or not
we're going to continue to strength of
Ukraine's ability to defend itself
particularly air defense and that's why
we're going to be providing Ukraine with
Patriot missile battery
the training you're forces to be able to
accurately use it
he's reading his little script maybe he
was written by the defense contractors
that just hosted an event in Washington
for the Ukrainian Ambassador literally
they put their logos on the invitation
just in case there was any question
about what's going on here so this is a
big change from what we had say last
month
but you wouldn't know that from the
media coverage of it your average
reporter in Washington like zelenski a
lot more than he likes you so nobody
asked about it but this is a major
policy change it was just a few months
ago that a senior U.S defense official
said and we're quoting there is no
discussion about putting a patriot
battery in Ukraine in order to do that
you would have to put U.S troops with it
to operate
in other words you would have to fight a
hot war against Russia which has not
only not been approved by the Congress
but most Americans have no idea that's
happening but now it is happening did
you know that
are you for that is it the most
important thing
more important than your nephew dying of
fentanyl yes is Mitch McConnell but it's
just the beginning because as you just
saw
zielinski has arrived in Washington to
make more demands he's the house guest
who would not leave and every moment we
tolerate him the demands become bigger
in case you missed it here's part of
what he said just a moment ago
financial's assistant is also critically
important and I would like to thank you
thank you very much thank you for both
Financial packages you have already
provided us with and the ones you may be
willing to decide on your money is not
charity
it's an investment in the global
security and democracy that we handle in
the most responsible way
so the leader of a foreign government
dressed in a sweatshirt waltzes into the
United States Congress
and starts demanding money and then as
the goal to tell the people sitting
there who are giving him tens of
billions of dollars more of your money
that it's not charity it's an investment
really what are the Returns on that
and by the way what's the point of it
what is the goal here what's the
justification for it do we have a
historic debt to Ukraine
do we have a historic animosity with a
non-soviet Russia no no
how do we win here what's in it for us
isn't this our country and where do you
get off talking to us like that do we
hate ourselves so much
do we have so little respect for the
United States of America that will put
up with that that will applaud it thank
you sir may I have another what's wrong
with us what's wrong with our leaders
and where's this going subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight